oh i'm a man
hmm
oh i'm hunting again this is gonna take
forever no no no no i'll be obvious i'll
keep it to within the the office you
ever heard there's a little tiny remote
on this uh map in the projector room
it's banned
not that i tried to immediately become
that or anything but it's you can't do
it oh yeah it's
banned in tournaments no here i go
i am in the office somewhere i'm not
outside
here's some cash guys someone take it
there's some cash
okay
i don't know what that was it was weird
oh that's so weird i rubber banded and
when i came back here they were gone
are you are you all right what's up with
your connection i don't know when i go
when i pass anything with like physics
in it my whole game freezes then i
teleport back and then back to where i
was weird you do own internet right
yeah
okay i don't know why it's
looking
it's like a horror movie
[Music]
that is a really inconvenient time for
this one
what a long taunt is that oh come on
let's talk about this one i mean yeah
man
where does that happen all right it's my
next
hey how's it going hey hey buddy how you
doing where you going
did you do this
did i do what
[Laughter]
i'm coming
[Laughter]
i think your footsteps might give you
away a little bit there oh can you hear
them
hey
[Music]
all right you got this oh
did that fire
that fire yeah it did on my screen it
didn't wait
where'd you go did you trigger that
no not intentionally i wish i could
trigger something for you
come back
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
oh no i [ __ ] lag crap i lost you
that's right you did
you're not gonna go through doors it's
unfair
i love that the thing you are still
makes footsteps no shot zero percent
chance that works
i had my nade left oh
way too dark stop
john there is nothing to see
are you
pleased
quickly farther away
[Laughter]
i wish you could be the laying down uh
filing cabinet that'd be sweet
give me rotation on all axes come on
cowards they would never they're too
scared yeah oh god oh what do i even do
what are you doing oh it happened again
what is your display i spawned a purple
oh i wish i wish this like actually did
what it was supposed to as we do it oh
yeah me too
so uh is this the plan
oh well i can't
[Laughter]
the same place he won't know uh yeah uh
what did you guys do uh nothing
or maybe if i kill one of you i can
freeze the other one all right uh
shoot him shoot him die
ask us a riddle another
correct answer oh yeah kill the tall one
kill the tall one i assume you mean the
one on top no wait don't no the opposite
of that
there's a phone over here watching us
[Laughter]
hurry mark i'll take a break for it
all right
oh thank you i was the tall one i'm
sorry mark you were the small one uh you
know it's not so bad really
sir look look look at the purple thing
look to your left look to your left
oh
didn't work oh
oh i'm scared i don't like this game
anymore oh god where'd you go
i don't know i'm frozen
what does the orb do by the way is your
special animal
type
i got 49 hp for free
whoa
good for you
oh yeah dude
[Applause]
[Laughter]
what just happened
hello no
way why am i not allowed change that's
funny because of what you are and saying
hello
[Laughter]
god the times
why do i still make footsteps hey how
you doing that's a really unfortunate
talk
uh yeah yeah yeah yeah here can you hold
this for me yeah
sure uh you know what i forgot those
explode when i throw them those are not
disposable
all right
hey
oh well this is
isn't there usually
one of these
how how do you know why do you know this
so well i
play counter strike a lot
yeah are you studying the [ __ ] phones
on the table
all right all right here you want you
want a chance you got a minute
thank you thank you guys sir thank you i
really appreciate it thank you so much i
really hope you don't taunt here in a
second that'd be real
oh god
i can't i'm not allowed to change into
anything else it won't let me
oh well that's kind of a problem
up there it goes i didn't see that i
didn't see that
come on man
here you thirsty is that one you
no
no it's not oh
no
you uh
here here uh hold
holy [ __ ]
[Laughter]
are you wrecking the place hold that for
me
you're so aggressive
all right never get me
oh no what will i do
lose
oh no
that's it your career's over no you
should be devastated you should be
devastated i am
no i won you don't get it excuse me
why is that happening oh christ
oh i've right clicked that was my bad
yeah can we like selectively is it pro
strats to taunt right before the round
starts so that people don't know
you found me
would you like some free hp
please or ammo you may take our purple
ball
please shoot the window over there
and allow me to leave
thank you kind sir enjoy your free house
both of you could leave no no we both
get to leave that's how this works the
other one's running away you should go
get them see now i know which one is
which
oh guys there's an unstuck button
oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
is it right next to the conference
f3 is unstuck ah oh right i knew that
oops oh all this running around is
making me tired no no nice fun that's a
great pun
rich win
the only smart one
what do you mean it's working he doesn't
even know where this window is
hey how's it going
bob you see the mysterious did not be in
the window as much what's happening
there was one
probably the one you'd expect this is
the most
uninteresting play oh i just i just want
to say
sorry the most uninspired
oh
you mean good you
mean oh you're going to win the game but
are you going to win at life yes taking
the low hanging fruit like this
or something maybe not now
look not only am i winning i should come
over to your house and sit on your chest
yeah i don't know this map well enough
i'm in the office but in an area you
might not know look at i think you're
late for a meeting but you with the
super accurate he has 30 seconds
i don't know where that is i think
you're late for a go to the room with
the table of with chairs around it i
don't know where that is they're just
projecting
on me i don't know where that is
upstairs
i'm frozen
you see bob this is this is what skill
is all about uh-huh
i'm broken winning easily by playing a
prop that no one's ever gonna find
because it's not interesting at all oh
okay i can't wait to see your prop
genius in the next round hey is this
markerweight who is this i'm following
you
not me i'm uh i'm the hunter but all
right what's up
all right hey master at work let's all
hide in the same place and see who does
the best job all right i will we will
all of us will
we will all of us will fight in the same
area
oh god this is the only thing it would
let me turn into
no
nope
nope
what if we
what if we
what are you wait what are you doing
what the hell is this then oh god oh he
[ __ ] me up
am i uh bob what do you think of my
skills now huh are you the one that's
moving or the one that's not moving the
bobby you don't even understand
hey guys how's it going hey hey hey
what's up so you have to as you discover
who we are where we are you have to rate
our hiding spots
all right well since we're all here i
want you guys to look at the graphs as
you can see two pounds part three was
really low this year
oh
my god
my ears does that answer your question
oh no one is that i thought one of you
was that
whoa
[Music]
what was that i was still unsure if that
was you bob and now i'm 100
sure
what was me you don't know what i am
wait don't be a coward take shots yeah
come on
coward all right well there goes the
meeting oh great good morning everybody
oh part of the projector landed on you
well yeah you're gonna find us if you go
around picking everybody up
you were supposed to use your wits wade
not your mind my witch tells me that one
of you is a chair nope
one of you
one of you is not mark that is this
chair nope and who am i i'm the winner
whoa wait wait wait wait wait here you
have to get all three you don't win on
two
oh
i guess it's not sean uh
eeny meeny miny
[Music]
wow
wow well i'm a head out
good meeting guys
really cool it's not over beating's not
over i i froze oh you're having some
trouble with the day
it's so sad it's freezes completely oh
mark you can't go there
that is the most boring
uninspired change you could have made
mark no not boring not uninspired it's
original and wait no stop
[Laughter]
give me one good reason you know what i
really thought
i really thought that was gonna work i
really thought it was too you know i i
you know
just because uh i actually want to say i
had the best hiding spot because and
i'll show you why because i moved this
here so that this chair was already here
and then when you came back i threw away
the chair that was there into the pilot
chairs and i took the place of this
chair assuming that your object
permanence was high enough that you
would be able to understand that this
chair was still here before and you
already had dismissed it but you made a
mistake you trusted my memory yeah
exactly that's what i'm saying your
flawed brain allowed was your downfall
you saw nothing
[Music]
oh god
wait wait wait wait don't you have to go
to the other room in real life for about
26 seconds
you're right hang on let me kill this
can then i'll leave
no never very nice at all oh
man he jumped right into it
hey i haunted more than once
yeah i i've not been hunter yet who's
the hunter
[Laughter]
what did knowing who the hunter is have
to do with you not standing in the
window it's a t-pose look we've all made
mistakes
where yeah bob i'm done i'm just doing
some legos the star wars i was trying to
just build like a tower you know
like a little like a little leaning
tower of a little tricky tower
bob i want you to judge how inspired and
creative um
i am this time
oh yes
i feel like you'll really appreciate my
genius
for what it really is yep and if you uh
if you were able to
understand that um
very very clever mark love it
you should just kill me if you find him
did you do that or was that the game i
don't know
we'll never know anyway my spot's so
goddamn good
yeah i already found them just for your
other two hiders just to let you know no
no no no
no oh my god it looked right
[Music]
so i know what's going to happen next
is he a chair in the meeting room
you can't see through my genius
how do you even remember what i was oh
this is sparta bob that was largely luck
i gotta say i'm really sorry you shot me
twice how does that look i thought you
bleeded you've done blooded the first
time which sort of gives it away
oh you [ __ ] is that where merrick's
sending her wade
marcus the chair wait is the t-pose
yeah let's go to the meeting i think we
should all go to the meeting no no no no
there's no meeting adjourned
either way just go one or the other
jesus christ
hey i didn't know the map either you're
good wait don't worry thank you
[Music]
all right hey mark how you doing
[Music]
okay good
i wasn't gonna let them win
why not
aha finally
victory will be mine all right mark time
for that big brain oh yeah
who's screaming in agony
oh if you find me
the smartest man alive
get to the chopper
is that a come on
is that a clue
really
did you not just see me
nope i did not because you're not here
okay good play in games with me
sure sure yeah i
don't
don't oh i hear noise somewhere
i love how you still make footsteps as
you run by what what the t is ready
[Laughter]
all right guys i forgot to take the
ticket oh hey
see you later friend
was there do i have a friend in here oh
i do hey what's up friend
oh friends am i detecting some friends
is this a friend no i saw you from
somewhere else
oh
hey listen
all right oh
yeah listening wade saw me from around
here so wade's around here too okay and
you can only kill one of us i'm pretty
sure
okay so you know you have to make your
choice which one you're gonna kill
really
[Laughter]
[Music]
so where'd you go
where did you go
come back here who are you oh no
why
oh [ __ ]
[Music]
who was it
no one nothing
it wasn't me that's mine
who's screaming
hello
oh no
it was from what they called downtown
wait a minute wait a minute
wait a minute
no
wait
ah it wasn't such a good spot everything
was perfect and bob would have big nog
i had to come barreling through like a
bear
[Laughter]
knocking over and breathing
you stuck
is he t posing again
maybe
[ __ ] sake wait
it is hold still
yeah
i hate that i die in a great spot when
you're just a bald man running around
hey
i take offense to that
you shoot man running around
i am a bald man and i don't get to run
really i'm gonna hunt you so hard in a
minute you won't even know what hit you
when i come
hmm oh i can't be those oh come on stop
lagging i need to move listen i didn't
realize you were out yet
oh i i didn't get a chance yet
i keep freezing turn your bald ass
around and you go back in that garage
i'm sorry
[Laughter]
hey wait go
i just want to live not i hate bald
people
[Laughter]
be sick with their bald and their lack
of hair you better shoot all the windows
then all right who did i let go to stare
at balderino down there i wasn't doing
did you see the fire hydrant fire
extinguisher i mean that thing
hey uh fellow props did you know you can
turn on your flashlight as a prop
yes whoa
what the [ __ ]
that's awesome it makes a good sound too
is that a global sound or nah
no
i don't know
it sounds like it should be global
no you didn't see it as a sneak i am
camouflaged
oh reassuring
listen this can go one of two ways
either you're lucky my sight only works
based on movement flinch
[Music]
it wasn't my intention you guys are
awfully quiet all of a sudden
i don't sound quite on my end
yeah sean he'll never suspect never
never not in a million years no way
don't you dare is this you no papers
uh-uh
you'll never catch me
uh i might
you'll never catch me
i really could
you'll never catch me now here we go
[Laughter]
that wasn't supposed to actually work
wait
i thought you actually lost them
it's so slow the trash can so slow the
trash can is slow yeah
yeah you got 12 seconds you better find
the file
cabinet
is that a good secret
bobby pin
in five seconds
unfortunately i really need to go to the
bathroom real quick ah okay you can wait
to vote on the map till you get back to
buy you 20 seconds
if we don't vote it pick it pick where
you guys want to go wherever it picks
[Music]
bye